learning how to monetize free is one of
the biggest Tools in your toolbox
dominoes offer some of you guys may
remember this delivered to your door in
30 minutes or it's free that's an
irresistible offer and they had
pizza but because of that they saw the
offering when they were hungry they were
like shooting 30 minutes I could have
pizza at my door the old six-speed
challenge that we ran for a very very
long time was a free six week challenge
put X dollars down you do X Y and Z you
can either get it back or you can get it
towards program whatever so it's a free
with deposit so free with stipulations a
good friend of mine owned a chain of
weight loss clinics and they made only
like five percent of the revenue on
service and they made 95 of their
revenue on supplements and so people
would come in and they'd essentially
give the the service away for free but
they were required to use the
supplements as a part of it so that's
kind of a free forever model which is
really understanding that how you can
monetize the second need the next thing
they're going to need after the first
thing